[Musique]
elles étaient seulement quelques
dizaines avant 2015 à sont désormais
plus de 550 les communes nouvelles sont
devenues tendance en france et 2018
semble marquer le début d'un engouement
aussi pour le département des yvelines
encore vierge en la matière bonsoir à
tous les communes nouvelles sont en
débat ce soir au concours et le chesnais
saint germain en laye et 3 3 communes
aussi aux alentours maisons laffitte et
le mesnil le roi coignard est morte à
les projets de fusion entre les communes
se multiplient ces temps ci dans les
yvelines et si certains sont rapidement
abandonnée d'autres pourraient devenir
réalité avant le 1er janvier prochain
les villes sont incités par l'état se
rapprocher pour réaliser des économies
et faire face à la baisse des dotations
mais les arguments financiers super
style réellement à créer une dynamique
et une volonté commune quelle place pour
les habitants aussi dans ces débats nous
allons poser ces questions à nos invités
du soir ils seront 3 normalement pour
l'instant ils sont deux michel barnier
riaz président de l'association ensemble
bailly noisy le roi reine moulin et
ludivine vent tourne ou membres du
collectif pour un référendum local
référendum que vous réclamez pour le
projet qui concerne notamment saint
germain en laye il y aura aussi et smile
havane qui va nous rejoindre conseiller
municipal socialiste de mort pas lui qui
était concernée par la fusion qui a été
finalement annulé entre maurepas et
coignières bonsoir à vous je le disais
la création de communes nouvelles est
une tendance qui s'est accélérée en
france on va voir tout de suite les
chiffres de l'insee à s'afficher à
l'écran ces chiffres s'arrête au 1er
janvier 2018 l'île de france n'est pas
pour l'instant trop concernés par le
mouvement notamment département des des
civils michel barnier ria ce vous vous
êtes un ancien élu de noisy-le-roi vous
souhaiter un rapprochement entre votre
commune et deux autres
deux autres villes pourquoi est-ce que
c'est l'argument financier qui prime
avant tout est ce que c'est ça le
principal argument pour guma financier
de pôle principal le principal quand on
regarde un peu de haut entre bailly
noisy le roi nous sommes encerclés
nous avons 90 % des gens qui sont
communes
nous avons un syndicat intercommunal
déjà pour le sport nous avons nous
sommes morts ça semble logique de bon
sens de le dire maintenir les dotations
de globale de fonctionnement qui joue
aussi
c'est ce que c'est l'effet tient par
derrière ou sait très bien que le
gouvernement veut pousser au
regroupement de façon à baisser
globalement les charges les dépenses au
niveau de la france entière
donc ça c'est vrai que ça pousse mais le
premier geste otages et de bon sens sous
cloche dans ce cas là pourquoi pourquoi
se tourner vers rennes moulin c'est
c'est pas avoir évolué s'est bâti red
bull est en fait qu est si précis parti
à vous lasser même pas un village sais
pas comment on peut nous même et ses 102
habitants voilà voilà le 112 habitants
locaux noisy on est à huit mille et
bayod de 4000 on peut se demander
pourquoi pas juste ces deux communes et
pourquoi la troisième semaine mais parce
que braid moulin des habitants du red
bull et viennent habiter viennent faire
leurs courses la vienne à la baisse à
noisy et bailly et cetera et cetera
donc ça paraît logique de paillage est
sur le bord de l'eau ludivine vent
tourne ou à saint germain en laye
là aussi c'est visiblement l'argument
financier qui semble primer quand on
regarde les arguments des différentes
communes sur les sites internet
pourtant saint germain en laye par
exemple est une ville assez riche
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un autre argument
qui est qui est caché derrière tout ça
peut-être sru qui est très difficile à
respecter 25 % de logements sociaux en
2025 alors lors des différentes réunions
publiques et lors des réunions
d'information qui a eu lieu pour
présenter la commune nouvelles ces
dernières semaines on a pu voir
différents arguments apparaître lors
d'une part le mouvement global qui
pourrait avoir sur la france comme vous
l'avez rappelé qu' beaucoup moins fort
sur la région ile de france notamment
puisqu'on n'a pas le même type de
regroupement de communes nouvelles
avec pas des communes rurales il ya
plusieurs types d'arguments et on les
retrouve sur les différents intérêts
agir aujourd'hui des villes en présence
à dire qu'il pourrait y avoir une
volonté politique et une volonté de
positionnement pour une ville comme
saint germain en laye est effectivement
des arguments qui sont davantage sur des
contraintes financières pour les autres
villes mais dans tous les cas l'argument
qui doit être principal et qui à notre
sens est vraiment motivant pour aller
s'engager davantage dans ce processus de
communes nouvelles c'est de créer un
véritable projet de territoire commun où
tous les territoires leur serait plus
attractif et horaires des réalités
concrètes tous les habitants s améliorer
le quotidien et ce projet pour l'instant
de territoire il existe selon vous c'est
vrai qu'on voit pas voir la carte
s'afficher mais le projet quand on voit
en tout cas d'un point de vue
géographique cette grande ville de saint
germain et ses trois petites villes qui
les entourent enfin débile quand même
d'une certaine taille mais qui les
entourent ou saint germain les
représenterait je crois 75 % de la
population totale de l'ensemble on a
peut-être un peu du mal à voir sur ces
quatre là le projet territoire on les
verrait peut-être plus sur les trois en
tout cas ensemble et trois villes qui
entourent qui qui sont au sud de saint
germain
effectivement quand on réfléchit à une
commune nouvelle on réfléchit à son
périmètre et c'est vrai que spontanément
quand on a été informés de cette volonté
de créer
une commune nouvelle c'est pas forcément
l'ensemble de ces villes qui sont venus
spontanément à l'esprit pour des
questions de 25 villes de mobilité de
coopération ancien tu peux exister et
c'est donc c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
voilà c'est pas forcément une évidence
et ne voit pas apparaître très
clairement le projet de territoire voire
même il nous paraît insuffisant
peut-être insuffisamment exposés ou en
tout cas comme le calendrier est assez
resserrée peut-être un peu précipité il
ne semble pas que ce projet territoire
s'inscrit dans un temps long et qui a pu
être identifiée par tous on va
d'ailleurs peut-être cité les trois
communes qui sont concernés par un peu
de tout à l'heure j'ai vite de les dire
mais il y a pour que les temps la ville
et la 4e excusez moi une petite commune
qui est ma marraine marie marly qui
était aussi grosse qu'une qui viennent
de rejoindre bonsoir je le disais vous
êtes conseiller municipal à maurepas du
coup vous avez vécu plus ou moins de
façon proche
la fusion avortée en tout cas le
rapprochement avorté entre maurepas et
quoi hier est ce que quand le sujet vous
avez été exposé c'est d'ailleurs c'est
principalement la primauté financière
qui a été mise en avant l'aspect
financier pour la ville de maurepas si
on mord pas ce qui a été mis en avant
effectivement c'est là la partie
financière et je partage certains propos
que je viens d'entendre sur le fait
qu'une fusion doit reposer sur un projet
de territoire avant tout mais surtout je
pense qu'une fusion réussit c'est une
fusion qui fait sens c'est à dire qu'on
n'a pas besoin de le dire
vous pouvez prendre l'exemple par
exemple div 2 evry et de courcouronnes
qui vont fusionner dans l'essonne ils
ont fusionné c'est un débat qui date
déjà depuis plusieurs années et la
population quand vous vous baladez dans
les quartiers de courcouronnes ou d'evry
pour les gens pour la population c'est
normal parce qu'ils en gardent commune
ils ont des associations qui sont qui
travaille entre elles et plus personne
ne fait la différence
et quand ça fait sens un projet de
territoire fonctionne bien je crois que
un peu arrivé comme ça sur à la une de
l'actualité son savoir comment ce que je
pense c'est que on devrait se donner les
moyens de faire sens et pour faire sens
faut des projets de territoire et il
faut se donner le temps parce que la
municipale en fait mais ce qui est
important
à force d'agréger les choses parce que
faut pas oublier quand même le contexte
dans lequel on est à maurepas
on vient juste d'intégrer saint quentin
en yvelines ce qui est déjà lourd saint
quentin en yvelines qui veut encore
s'agrandir et en plus et en plus
maintenant on veut fusionner pourquoi
pas mais tout cela est ce que ça a un
sens pour l'habitant est ce qu'on perd
pas en raison en utilité en projets
sociaux en projet de territoire
c'est la question je crois qu'il faut se
poser c'est quelle utilité pour les
habitants et la meilleure utilité pour
les habitants c'est un projet de
territoire et c'est surtout se donner le
temps rien nous oblige de nous presser
alors l'argument financier a été mis en
avant par la loi puisque comme vous le
savez il y a des avantages financiers
sur trois ans est-ce que c'est petit
pour des communes qui ont pour certaines
sentant l'histoire je crois qu'on doit
aller aux tirs au-delà de cela sur
l'argument justement kit avance puisque
vous vous souhaitez le rapprochement
entre trois communes est ce que cette
vision presque à court terme parce que
trois ans et très peu finalement
est ce que vous comprenez ça que c'est
un peu petit comme argument finalement
ce que c'était plus petits que leurs
vues m'ont absolument
je pense que le mot a été présenté plus
tôt les limons été présenté le projet de
territoire points en tout cas faut bay
voisines ont droit il existe quand on
n'existe pas mais il permettra d'en
faire or actuellement on peut pas en
faire historique passé assez lointaine
éventuellement on peut pas en faire un
projet médical par exemple avoir une
maison médicale le même projet au point
de vue transport entre les lieux d'un
bout à l'autre de l'agglomération il ya
quand même deux kilomètres et demi trois
kilomètres il a perçu des personnes
âgées peuvent pas se déplacer vous des
dix projets une fusée concrètement
pourrait permettre de créer
en direct des peut très bien imaginer ce
qui se passe dans certaines villes un
petit bus électriques qu'ils fassent les
retours en permanence entre les deux
extrémités il ya quand même trois
kilomètres entre les extrémités de
communes
voyez bon des bricoles comme ça peuvent
se mettre en place sur l'ensemble or que
chacune valu à riom ce qu'on appelle moi
je vais jusque là bas j'étais mais les
lillois ont eu une réaction à vendre
avant d'avoir un sujet sur sur la fusion
qui est bien entamée par contre le
chesnay et rocquencourt
oui tout à fait pour un peu rebondir sur
cette question de mutualisation je pense
que il faut insérer vraiment un projet
comme une nouvelle dans une
collaboration anciennes et avoir déjà
testé un certain nombre de mises en
commun d'équipements d'interconnexion de
mise en commun du côté de saint germain
en laye avec les autres communes alors
récemment il ya eu une police municipale
avec marie marly mais c'est vrai que
c'est très récent
c'est pas généraliser il y à d'autres
services sur lesquels ils pourraient
avoir des pistes avec ses villas
éventuellement avait d'autres et je
rejoins aussi le fait qu' il faut que
tous les acteurs concernés puissent
avoir appris à se connaître à travailler
en ce sens aussi bien les élus je dirais
que les agents faut pas oublier que
c'est aussi très important parce que la
mutualisation passe aussi par les
services mais aussi des habitants avec
le côté associations collaboration
sportive ou autre et je pense que c'est
ce qui menace cette histoire commune
qu'on en arrive à écrire ensemble un
projet de territoire en commun c'est
bien la balle juste rapidement cette
histoire commune elle s'écrit depuis
quelques mois depuis quelques années
entre mortain croyait il ya une police
maintenant inter intercommunale il y a
aussi beaucoup de services qui sont qui
sont mises en commun il va avoir une
piscine vous connaissez bien le sujet en
en commun aussi
moi je crois qu'il ya des choses dans la
vie qui se décrète pas ça serait pas
l'étape suivante est logique finalement
se décrète pas il ya des choses qui se
décrète pas savoir travailler ensemble
ça s'apprend il faut connaître les gens
il faut connaître le territoire
vous parlez de coignières et de maurepas
ces deux territoires qu un bassin de vie
complètement différent maurepas et très
orientées vers la nos villes nouvelles
alors que connurent
et très orientées vers le sud yvelines
est d'ailleurs coignières se définit
comme ville à la campagne ce qui est pas
mort pas avoir passé une commune urbaine
quoi qu'on en dise donc quand vous
questionner les habitants et j'en
reviens là parce que c'est assez là
l'essentiel
les habitants et de coignières et vous
dise quoi ils vous disent nous on se
sent pas dans ce truc là on se reconnaît
pas là dedans c'est pas notre bassin de
vie et pourquoi ce n'est pas leur bassin
de vie parce qu'il ya jamais eu de
construction ou de projets communs pour
apprendre à travailler ensemble et faire
sens dans les années à venir et donc ce
que je crois c'est que les temps
ça demande du temps et c'est pour ça que
j'ai employé le terme petit tout à
l'heure l'argumentaire l'agglo financier
qui alléchant mais précipite on va
disputer cet argument financier un gel
en gros de la dotation globale de file
de fonctionnement gelé pour trois ans et
qui m'aime je crois bonifié de 5%
c'est vrai qu'en ces temps où on reçoit
on multiplie les élus sur ce plateau qui
se plaignent à juste titre d'une baisse
de 7 des gf c'est un argument qui peut
aussi être convaincant c'est un argument
qui peut être convaincant encore une
fois dans les territoires qui font sens
je lis d'evry celui de courcouronnes etc
la question se pose pas parce que le
travail et la région la rose est aussi
un jour à cette question il a fallu
peut-être commencé à mener le projet
d'une manière soir si vous me permettez
vous prenez morte à elancourt un projet
de fusion ferait sens parce que
l'histoire de ces deux villes fait qu'
il y a déjà une mutualisation fait
depuis des années et la construction de
devil fait par ibou est fait de telle
façon qu'elles sont interconnectés et de
la surface après sa fessée à
montigny-le-bretonneux lui encore qui
diront non parce que après ça fera une
méga ville je pense une interco je peux
me permettre à jour des gens qui
porteront le nom pour l'instant la vie
des populations et les coûts on va en
découler
je vous propose avant avant avant d'en
parler de ça va être la deuxième partie
de notre débat je vous propose de
regarder ce sujet sur la fusion bien
amorcé entre le chez nero concours cette
semaine les élus des deux villes se sont
prononcés pour en conseil municipal
les précisions avec ce sujet de michael
et demi d'euros le chez nero concours
vont bientôt former une seule et même
commune les deux conseils municipaux ont
voté ce lundi 18 juin le principe de
faisabilité d'une fusion cette nouvelle
ville regroupera sous le nom le chesnais
rocancourt trente deux mille habitants
début janvier 2019 avec un seul maire à
sa tête
nous nous avons travaillé depuis le mois
de septembre régulièrement pour
apprécier le bien fondé de cette
nouvelle commune
et quand nous avons fait nos deux
colonnes le pour et le contre et bien
avons vu qu'au mois de mars le colonnes
pour était quasiment rempli dans la
colonne des pour selon les élus cette
mesure permettra au concours de
bénéficier des structures et des
services de la ville du chesnay dans le
sens inverse les chesnaysiens pourraient
eux réaliser des économies en réduisant
notamment les indemnités sur le manque
de logements sociaux c'est
l'optimisation des dépenses qui est
importante même s'il y a effectivement
une dotation globale de fonctionnement
qui est bonifié et même si effectivement
sur l'arrêté de carence il y aura plutôt
des bons résultats et nous aurons aussi
également de bonnes actions d'urbanisme
dans ce sens aux chaînés la fusion
recueilli 30 et une voix pour et 2
contre l'opposition a critiqué le manque
de communication conseil municipal et
aurait préféré une autre orientation
stratégique pour la ville
considérons que la cette fusion arrive
bien tardivement
parce que la vie leur concours est
beaucoup trop petit désormais pour pour
fusionner avec le chesnay dans les
circonstances actuelles il faut
fusionner plus tôt avec une grande ville
concurrence versailles pour arriver une
taille critique puissante pour peser
dans le grand paris prochaine étape la
présentation globale du projet le 8
octobre prochain le futur nom des
habitants n'est lui pas encore connue
pourrait être sommé une consultation sur
internet
on le voit bien avec ce reportage que
finalement surtout pour la ville du
chesnay l'avantagé et financier par
rapport à la loi sru juste pour revenir
sur ce raid moulin pour insister avant
de passer aux côtés dé mocratique 112
habitants qu'est ce que vous allez dire
aux habitants de rennes moulin pour les
convaincre par exemple si ce projet de
fusion se fait qu' ils ont intérêt à
avoir rejoint hormis de lorgner sur
leurs terres agricoles que soit leur âge
selon bien sûr ils n'ont pas grand chose
à leur dire
il profite déjà de bailly noisy le roi
ils payent des impôts qui n'ont pas de
commune mesure et que les appeaux anosy
l'ovni droit jeumont certes on a 12 ans
pour que les impôts une arche jouannic
c'était soit harmonisée mais enfin on
leur en parlera j'avais personnellement
j'ai fondé une association ensemble pays
de loire et moulins
j'ai écrit au maire de renwez m'a pas
répondu
donc continueront à mon avis a profité
ce alors on leur proposera à la canton
salariat ce que voulaient fusionner ce
que diront les citoyens rapidement puis
on pourra alesi alesi a destitué liste
ici ici on discute c'est ainsi qu'est ce
que selon vous que pas un problème de
méthode
parce que quand je vous entends parler
en monsieur n'est pas d'ailleurs je dis
que si ce n'est pas un n'est pas maire
ou élu et c'est à 10 ans qui propose un
projet
je vous précise et j'avais bien compris
est ce qu'il ya un problème de méthode
est ce que vous dites on leur dira alors
que ça a été voté
si je comprends bien au conseil
municipal déjà non pas du tout j'ai au
bourget créé une association
d'accord mais dont le but est ce que les
listes municipales de 2001 mettent à
leur programme la réunion la fusée
absents reconnu que les retardataires et
pourtant vous voyez bien sûr je suis
content parce que c'est un projet qui
inscrit à l'avant ce but après la danse
de la population ce qui n'est pas le cas
de mort pas le cas de mort pas c'est
arrivé comme un cheveu sur la soupe
et ça c'est quand même problématique
parce que quelque part au moment de
l'élection municipale celle qui fait foi
on vote pour une liste y avait pas ce
projet là et donc du coup c'est quand
même prendre les abidjan je dirais à
revers il ya un autre élément du coup si
vous savez on est à présent temps de
mémoire vous porterez un projet de
fusion avec les craintes qu'elle emploie
oui nous on l'a dit aux patrons portant
après un projet de fusion avec elle en
cours il ya quelque chose
si vous mettez aussi qu'il faut
remarquer sur un projet de fusion
allez-y c'est sur les le taux de
logements sociaux et ça revient donc il
faut pas se laisser berner comme il ya
un certain nombre de communes dans les
yvelines qui respectent pas ce taux de
logements sociaux 25% de fusionner par
exemple le cas de maurepas et de
coignières aurait permis à mort par
exemple qui ne respectent pas ce taux-là
de d'échappée justement à cette
construction obligatoire parce que
compenser largement par air par
coignières et ça ça pose un problème
puisque ça veut dire que sur les
territoires
on peut avoir des endroits où des
territoires qui se voit plus à même à
recevoir la dation que d'autres on va
passer au débat démocratique
on va dire sur l'aspect démocratique
pour peut-être un peu plus concerné
encore encore les citoyens puissent cure
on rappelle que s'il ya fusion fusion
les villes sont obligé d'acter leur
fusion un an avant les élections
municipales c'est la loi qui l'obligent
elles ont donc jusqu'en mars 2010neuf
donc c'est très très rapide
c'est dans quelques mois dans neuf mois
ça laisse peu de temps aux débats c'est
votre critique à vous
principal en tout cas sur la fusion du
côté de saint germain ce que vous voulez
c'est qu' il y ait un référendum local
vous estimer aujourd'hui que les
habitants ce ne sont pas assez associés
aux débats
oui tout à fait et pour rebondir en
partie sur la question précédente c'est
vrai qu' on est dans l'idée qu'il faut
partager partager les expériences
s'inspirer de ce qui fonctionne ou ce
qui fonctionne pas aujourd'hui les
retours sur les communes nouvelles ou en
terme financier on attend encore des
études on sait que ça mettra une dizaine
d'années à pouvoir éventuellement
dégager de véritables économies
d'échelle en tout cas ce qu'on sait
c'est que quand un projet de commune
nouvelle respecte le fait qu'ils
s'inscrivent dans le long terme qui est
une vision qu'ils soient partagés par le
plus grand nombre est clairement
identifiée par l'ensemble des citoyens
elle fonctionne c'est les conditions
vraiment de réussite du projet donc nous
en ce moment c'est que au delà de
l'information ou qu'elle corresponde
quand même assez largement les quatre
réunions publiques de ces derniers temps
et l'ensemble des réunions publiques qui
a pu se tenir au delà du questionnaire
qui est mis en ligne qui à ses partiels
peut-être interrogations des salaires
qui sont faites il ya beaucoup de choses
j'avais tellement à ce que
personnellement sur les sites internet
on trouve presque très facilement des
informations sur le projet comme une
nouvelle mais voulait aller plus loin
avec un référendum local
voilà vous avez dit nous on trouve très
facilement de l'information sur le
projet de communes nouvelles à la fois
le dispositif mais par contre sur
véritablement le projet territoire sur
le fond du sujet ça a suffisamment on
n'a pas forcément mobilisé deux groupes
de travail pour réfléchir sur ce qu'on
pouvait faire ensemble
est ce que c'est une solution à ce que
c'est la solution miracle finalement de
demander aux habitants ce qu'ils en
pensent directement écoutez on l'a fait
de façon impromptue de façon on a
distribué un tract dans toutes les
boîtes aux lettres leur demandant ce
qu'ils pensaient avec les besoins à ce
qu'il voulait il est et où il était
content on a reçu 150 réponses donc plus
haut niveau la population de bailly que
de noisy or bailly qui nouvelle
municipalité
assez content pour les matières très
contre se trouve que 70% des gens qui
ont répondu de bailly veulent fusionner
pour le fusionner donc si vous pour nous
pourquoi pas donc c'est quand même si
une fois c'est même si une nouvelle fois
c'est pas vous qui décidez je trouve que
par derrière au fond d'eux mêmes quand
on dit que pays veut pas fusionner la
mérite pas il va pas refuser
elle possède pas les habitants du nombre
des retours qui sont mentionnés lors
d'une réunion publique à fort que le
cabinet de conseil qui accompagne
l'étude indiqué qu'il y avait 200
questionnaires environ qui était rempli
à l'heure actuelle nous on demande un
référendum local puisque là on va d'une
part pouvoir avoir un processus
d'adopter d'adoption la commune nouvelle
identité dans les calculs
aujourd'hui on est sur une adoption qui
peut être à plusieurs vitesses des
votations dans certaines villes
une absence de votation dans d'autres
donc déjà il ya un problème de fond
n'est pas sur une méthode commune et en
plus les seuls la question du référendum
permettrait une mobilisation plus
massive à la fois puisqu'on a parlé
aussi de médiatiser la paix revient
d'ailleurs et pour qu'ils puissent
véritablement avoir du sens il faut
atteindre le seuil
demandé pour des inscrits une réaction
sur ce référendum local assez rapidement
parce que j'aurai une dernière question
à vous poser il nous reste trois minutes
donc si vous pouviez enfin répondu
pensent qu un référendum local est une
excellente idée je dirais que c'est le
minimum parce qu'il faut s'adresser et
demandé la vie à la population
mais je suis quand même mitigé parce
qu'on est dans un processus sont en
avance à marche forcée est-ce qu'il
n'est même pas trop tard parce que sur
quoi on va s'interroger pour
s'interroger interroger la population
faudrait les interroger sur du fond sur
des projets concrets mais là on va
interroger les gens sur voulez-vous
fusionner ou pas fils de d donc
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que les gens je
pense vous répondre il vendrait beaucoup
répondre sur l'affect et ce dont on a
besoin c'est pas des réponses sur
l'affect c'est des réponses enfin des
questions et des réponses de fond sur
des projets de territoire et c'est ce
qui manque cruellement aujourd'hui
une dernière remarque puisque ces
projets de fusion en rappelle un autre à
un beaucoup plus gros je voulais avoir
votre avis sur une question c'est si
départementale le rapprochement qui a
été entamée depuis maintenant un peu
plus d'un an depuis plusieurs années
même entre le département des yvelines
et des hauts-de-seine
là c'est un peu en suspens en attendant
les annonces sur sur la métropole du
grand paris rapidement est ce que vous
êtes pour un rapprochement des deux
départements pour les mêmes raisons
mutualisation économie meilleur
fonctionnement et si oui ou non juste
pourquoi très rapidement 30 secondes
j'ai pas étudié le problème est sérieux
et bien sûr je veux bien croire que ça
va porter à quelque chose je suis pas
sûr que ça vaille la peine je pense que
derrière ça il ya une volonté politique
ou dessus qui veut que les 90
départements ce soit
30-40 qui est pas tous à laval là aussi
cette question là me pose problème
j'en reviens encore l'essentiel à la
population fait un sondage dans la rue
quasiment plus de personnes j'en suis
surpris d'ailleurs sont au courant de
cette fusion malgré l'effort c'est ce
que j'allais dire malgré l'effort des
médias et des télés donc ça ça pose
problème ça empêche pas quand même le
département d'avancé on n'a que trente
secondes
moi je partage complètement de votre
avis et je pense que c'est une question
éminemment politique
c'est assez difficile de rentrer dans le
sujet en 30 secondes qui le dépassent
deux personnes de concurrence aussi par
rapport au grand paris et donc c'est un
sujet que se sont appropriés les élus au
détriment de la population les divines
van tourneau malheureusement c'est le
piège de terminer derrière vous concluez
c'est une chance mais vous avez peu de
temps cette question là sur la question
du rapprochement tribunaux de sel alors
c'est aussi la même problématique que
j'ai évoqués sur le fait de ne pas
développer une commune nouvelle à
plusieurs vitesses je pense que le
rapprochement entre le 118 et 92 se
tenait aussi au fait de lutter contre
développement d'une de france à
plusieurs vitesses et pouvait être un
argument supplémentaire pour revoir les
frontières du grand paris et du cloud
insérer davantage de communes dans cette
dynamique
merci à vous trois merci d'être venu sur
ce plateau c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le
débat prochaine émission jeudi prochain
à 18h30 en direct d'ici là vous
retrouver cette émission replay sur tv
78 points comme ou l'application tv 78
merci une nouvelle fois et bonne soirée
à tous
[Musique]